Hey everyone Diavolo here and today we are
diving right back into Jujutsu kaisen and
the current beatdown going on between two
of the universes strongest fighters.
Yes this is the Decisive Satoru Gojo Vs Ryomen
Sukuna Battle in the uninhabited, Demon-Infested
district of Shinjuku (or at least everything
so far).
Nothing that I could think of throughout the
series, bar maybe Sukuna Vs Mahoraga, even
comes close to the scale of cursed energy
consumption or destruction that we bear witness
to here.
This is truly an amazing fight to behold and
encapsulates everything that makes Jujutsu
Kaisen so freaking good!
So if you are new around here make sure to
subscribe to keep upto date with all of Jujutsu
Kaisen, and if you do enjoy the video make
sure to leave a like and try push this to
to 5k likes so I know you all want to see
more.
But either way sit back and relax as we watch
Shinjuku get wiped from reality.
Well I guess ill take everything back to the
moment we kicked off, and yes of course massive
manga spoilers for any anime only’s who
happened to stumble across this fight.
Any who, as all of the Sorcerers were lacking
out discussing how to give Gojo a boost of
confidence, as its the first time they’re
really ever needed too.
Gojo himself, accompanied by Gramps and Utahime
all with looks of determination, then roll
up to get ready for battle.
With everyone around feeling his aura, Yuji
greets his sensei wholeheartedly and lets
him know that he cant get close cause his
Techniques in the way.
Gojo is slightly surprised, but after a moment
ends up laughing while telling his boy to
give it to him, causing Yuji to jump up and
slap his Sensei on the back.
Then following on the same path, every other
sorcerer patted Gojo on the back as he rolled
through the group on his way to the battlefield.
Walking through a skyscraper with Gojo, Ijichi
notes that it feels like ages since he was
last here, when in all reality its only been
just over a month now.
Wanting to know what the realm felt like,
Gojo explains to Ijichi that the Prison Realm
was like when ya mad busy with work that it
flashes in a week, however the feelings so
draining you'd never want to experience it
again.
A few moments later, Gojo inquires about the
people in the basement of Shibuya’s metro
station where all the chaos started.
If we’re being specific, that’s where
Gojo came across Choso, Hanami and Jogo.
Even though Gojo fought them for a very short
period of time, it left remnants of Gojo’s
cursed energy that made Cursed Spirits avoid
the floor entirely.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY INSANE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, THIS MAN IS SO STRONG EVEN HIS RESIDUALS
SCARE CURSED SPIRITS.
Ijichi also reveals that the people who were
affected by his 0.2-second domain are all
fine and those that were effected returned
to normal.
Walking up behind Gramps and Utahime atop
the roof, Gojo and Ijichi arrive as the day
of reckoning has begun.
Elsewhere Uraume asks what time the fights
going to take place, to which Sukuna reveals
that they didnt specify a time, but as he
says that he’s able to feel Gojo’s aura
emanating in his direction.
Back in the hallway just moments before they
made it to the roof, Ijichi confronted Gojo
on why he wanted him to construct the barrier.
Turning back and looking at his close friend,
Gojo tells him that its because he trusts
him more than anyone else.
Now atop the roof and slamming his hands onto
the ground in preparation for his barrier,
Ijichi just thinks on how he’s someone who
always fled, no someone who didnt even have
the courage to flee and was given the courage
to run by a friend.
Despite everything Ijichi braces himself and
notes that he must live up to Gojo’s expectations,
either that or die trying!
Infront of the two and while using her cursed
Technique called Solo Forbidden Arena.
Its explained that any sorcerer of her choosing,
including Utahime herself, will have their
cursed energy reserves and output temporarily
enhanced as long as they remain in range.
To excel at Jujutsu is to excel at subtraction.
The degree to which a sorcerer can omit cadence,
movement and other elements that relate to
their cursed technique determines their skill,
and Utahime leaves nothing.
Words, Gestures, Dance, Music.
Elevating the simple technique to that of
a ritual boosts its effectiveness by 120%.
Utahime’s CT allows her to boost the chosen
sorcerer’s cursed energy and as Gojo himself
also begins chanting to add to his own technique
“Nine Ropes, Polarized light, crow and declaration,
between front and back, its revealed that
just like our girl, Gojo also never left anything
out and with the combination of the trio’s
cursed energy shoots forth his 200% hollow
purple.
As Gojo’s ability blasts forth, Sukuna manages
to take notice of it and throws up his hands
trying to block the entire attack, with the
buildings all around him exploding due to
hollow purple, Sukuna’s defenses are undoubtedly
breached as the building he was standing on
is completely demolished, causing it to fall
to the ground below.
Uruame who was next to Sukuna at the time
of attack has also not been since this moment,
correct me if im wrong, but after this
attack she’s seemingly vanished.
Either way.
As the smoke slowly fades its made evident
that due to Ijichi’s barrier Sukuna actually
misread Gojo’s first move, like even though
he knew where he was he didnt sense the insane
cursed energy output until the last moment.
Bursting through the smoke, SUKUNA with one
less hand someone managed to tank the first
attack leaving the true battle between history
and todays strongest sorcerers to continue.
So back before the blast, Sukuna and Uraume
were located at Shinjuku Center which is around
4-5 kilometers away from the Shibuya building
Gojo was currently on with his team.
Having strolled across that distance in a
matter of moments Gojo sets the record straight
and tells the king of curses that he’s the
challenger here!
The Challenger?
Sukuna standing there finds it utterly pathetic
that Gojo would state that after landing a
surprise attack.
In his eyes and as he brings his hands together
Gojo is no more than a fish atop his chopping
board, one slightly fresher but still just
a nameless fish.
Flaring up his cursed energy, Sukuna just
remarks that its time he start peeling back
Gojo’s scales.
Gojo Asks him why he’s still wearing that
face and guesses that Sukuna’s original
thought was to steal Megumi’s body so he’d
hold back.
Unfortunately for him, our mans been through
a specific set of training that allows him
to go all out on anyone who resembles any
sort of resemblance to the great Toji Fushiguro.
Considering that Gojo himself trained Megumi,
he he probably knows exactly how many hits
his student could take before he’s die,
and Given that Sukuna had survived death while
possessing Yuji, Gojo thought it would be
prudent to only start worrying about Megumi’s
welfare after he kills the person in control.
Initiating the conflict, the duo dart at each
other, both just narrowly dodging each successive
strike.
Dropping to the floor, just out of range of
Sukuna, Gojo flicks his hand straight into
his opponents nuts, sending them shooting
through the side of a nearby building and
out the other, crashing into some stairs behind
it.
Getting up, he’s instantly harassed by Gojo
who stomping in his direction, proceeds to
kick him in the gut so he’s perfectly placed
into the middle of a overpass bridge platform.
Continuing to stomp down, Gojo collapses the
platform Sukuna was on, making his footing
extremely unstable.
Taking the opportunity to catch him off-guard,
Gojo activates his infinity and levitates
the bridge into the sky, before tossing it
directly at a larger skyscraper.
Resisting the force of the platform, Sukuna
uses dismantle or what I assume to be dismantle
to cause the structure to collapse.
Making it over to a nearby roof in the flash
of an eye, Sukuna pulls up his hand and sends
a massive slice using dismantle to cut the
building directly behind Gojo in half.
With our man turning around to look at it,
Sukuna quickly rushes him throwing a fat right
hook that catches Gojo off-guard, however
as the punch connects with his infinity he
decides his technique in on order to physically
take Sukuna inside of the collapsing structure.
Following him up a hallway, Gojo quickly opens
a door that for a moment blinds the two fights
from seeing exactly what ability they’re
about to throw at each-other.
Catching them both off-guard though, the building
crashes into the ground bringing the previously
intense fight to a brief pause.
Walking out of the debris while all of the
smoke slowly starts to disperse, Gojo jokes
that well, he’s gonna pin all this destruction
on him once he gets outa here.
Sukuna points out that he really cant say
anything, quickly making Gojo realize that
Mei’s actually streaming this entire fight.
So
when it comes
to
down to Gojo’s limitless technique, it allows
him to be completely untouchable.
To get around this and in a similar way to
what Hanami and Jogo did, Sukuna is using
domain amplification to neutralize his cursed
technique.
Confused slightly on what Domain amplification
is, Yuta explains to everyone while they watch
the fight that he saw something similar in
Mechamaru’s footage.
He pretty much said what I said before about
Jogo and Hanami.
Hakari points out that it does seem like Gojo’s
domain has been neutralized, but he’s still
confused how.
The old G Kusakabe lets them all know though
that its more of a refined version of a simple
domain.
If one sheaths themselves in a domain without
imbuing your own cursed technique, you allow
the opponents technique to flow into that
empty space, thereby neutralizing it.
Angel points out that the main draw back to
domain amplifications are that you can simultaneously
use your own innate technique, no one not
even Sukuna is an exception to this rule.
So in here eyes, if Sukuna has another way
to deal with limitless other than Domain Amp,
then Gojo will lose.
Confused on why they don't just use a domain
expansion, Miwa enquires as to why.
She knows that immediately following the Domain,
ones technique becomes unstable so it would
make sense for Sukuna to challenge a domain
battle first.
Kirara notes that is easy to say that, but
depending on the outcome of that domain battle,
the fight would be over, which in both of
there eyes is the correct battle strategy.
Yuji though having been told something by
Gojo reveals that he’s pretty sure the domains
sure hit effect negates Gojo’s technique
to begin with.
Perking up, Ui Ui wonders if its because Sukuna
doesn't think he can win in a domain struggle
against Gojo.
Still Shoko points out that well yeah your
right but he probably would have opened one
if that was the case, so she finds it hard
to believe that Gojo wouldn't be able to foresee
that.
Standing there, Choso ponders the question
of what would happen if Gojo’s domain did
clash, as from what he was told Sukuna’s
domain is barrier-less.
Hearing this bizarre statement, everyone just
reacts in shock, unable to believe that his
domain doesn't have a barrier.
As an example of how its just impossible,
Kusakabe asks Miwa to toss him that water.
However after she gives him the bottle he
throws it back, telling her to give him the
water not the bottle.
Confused, Miwa facials the absolute hell out
of Kusakabe, while in behind them Mei San
explains that expanding a domain without a
barrier is just like trying hold water without
a bottle.
With no container, can you even accumulate
water?
Can you paint on thin air without a canvas?
with no stem, roots or leaves can a flower
bloom from a seed?
Maki compares it to like using software without
even having a pc to run anything on.
Its frankly unfathomable in their eyes, completely
impossible.
Even still she notes that Megumi’s Domain
was never enclosed within a barrier, and having
heard of that before Megumi was given his
grade promotion, Kusakabe explained that to
use it he had to use an existing structure
to enclose his domain.
Noritoshi Kamo or just good ole Kenjaku though
was able to pull it off so it does prove that
it can happen.
Choso who actually fought during that battle
pointed out that they’d prepared to use
a simple domain on Kenjaku while Tengen dismantled
his domain from the outside, however because
of the barrierless domain it was the simple
domain that was torn apart.
Miwa who’s confused over what exactly would
clash, states that the sure hit effect is
imbued within the barrier itself, so it can
only clash with another barrier.
She also realizes that well everyone's talking
as if there domains are a given, but domains
devour an insane amount of cursed energy,
so wouldn't avoiding using them make sense?
Inumaki speaks up and notes that well it doesn't
really matter since Gojo has infinite cursed
energy.
Ino knows its just due to how skilled he is
at using his technique, if his cursed energy
consumption rate ends up being less that what
he replenishes, then it could run out.
Thats just working under the assumption he’s
using it like normal though, if he changes
things up and states using domains consecutively,
then it could also be another story.
Not having even mentioned what Sukuna is capable
of, Kashimo speaks up to state that the sharpness
of his techniques activation is unparalled.
The way he can switch things up in a matter
of milliseconds, from innate technique to
domain amplification is amazing.
If Gojo literally wasn't who he isn't, then
Sukuna would comfortably be winning in terms
of cursed energy utility.
What's more, his total cursed energy is probably
even more than Yuta’s, from what he can
physically tell he’d say its probably double.
Momo who’s been pretty quiet this entire
chat, pops up as she feels that maybe nobody,
not even them knows how this is going to play
out.
If Gojo and Sukuna’s Domains do clash who
knows what's gonna happen, then right on that
exact moment and after all of the build up
we just went through.
Higuruma signals that they are about to begin,
the Domain Clashes.
Back in Shinjuku, both Sukuna and Gojo throw
up their respective hand signals to simultaneously
open, the infinite void and malevolent shrine.
With Sukuna now appearing above his shrine
and Gojo standing a few feet back, its explained
that the two are evenly matched.
They form a perfect pair within Gojo’s barrier,
which in turn meant that both guaranteed hits
overlapped each other then canceled themselves
out.
In this battle with as the two expand their
domains, should either one of them sustain
severe damage, it will cause the collapse
of their domain and the other ones sure hit
will immediately take effect.
Back at the TV room, Kusakabe and Mei Mei
both react in shock as somehow even with the
domains active they’re still evenly matched.
In Shinjuku the pure force of the two overlapping
domains causes the surrounding area to start
getting atomized.
Sadly for Gojo, the effective range of Sukuna’s
domain reaches even beyond that of a barrier,
and just as Yuji notes that a domain expansion
is weak from the outside, Gojo’s domain
cracks and shatters as its shown that below
it Sukuna’s domain now sits perfectly fine.
With no protection against Sukuna’s Sure
hit technique, the effect immediately fly's
forth and seemingly cuts down the strongest
sorcerer of today!
Having taken the slash to his neck, Gojo nonchalantly
activates his RCT, which everyone back at
the lair reacts to.
Higuruma states that as long as Gojo stays
in range, the slashes will never stop coming.
Choso who assumes escaping is probably the
port of call for Gojo, is backed by Hakari
who somewhat agree with him.
However its more that Hakari assumes Gojo
will make a dash for the exit, whereas Kusakabe
realizes that teleporting is out of the question
since its an application of the limitless
technique.
Due to the use of his domain expansion and
it being destroyed its plausible that for
a moment he cant use his cursed technique.
Which like they state, means he’s in store
for one hell of a beatdown.
Back inside of Sukuna’s Domain Expansion,
Gojo is relentlessly slashed over and over
again by the sure hit effect of the Domain.
Somehow though Gojo manages to calm himself
as he knows for a fact now that when it comes
down to techniques, his limitless is far better.
Having been able to consistently overpower
Sukuna’s sure hit effect with his use of
RCT, Gojo just like what everyone had expected,
makes a dash for the exit.
Sukuna immediately makes a dash to keep up
with him while remarking that he isn't just
gonna let him escape.
Grabbing his leg though Gojo still while constantly
getting slashed, pulls him in and knee’s
Sukuna into the floor.
Towering over him, Gojo attempts to land a
curse energy infused overhand, but misses
only cracking the floor as Sukuna quickly
manages to weasel his way out.
Standing there and looking at his opponent,
Sukuna remarks that Gojo’s still moving
pretty well considering he’s been activating
his reversed cursed technique at full output
in order to survive the constantly slashing.
Gojo on the otherhand, notices something extremely
important, to him it looks like Malevolent
Shrine itself is the heart of the domain,
not Sukuna.
Back inside of the headquarters, Yuji ponders
what would happen if someone destroyed the
shrine?
The big brain, Kusakabe brings up that objects
inside of domains don't tend to hold any special
meaning or significance, so think of it as
if it wasn't even there.
Mei san thinks that if it is a symbol of the
domain, then you wouldn't even be able to
destroy it and even considering Gojo’s inside
skills, it doesn't look like he’s taken
any measures to destroy it.
Suddenly Gojo activates the New Shadow Style,
Simple Domain taking Kusakabe by surprise
as he probably didnt expect it.
Yuji though noted that Gojo said one time
he could use it, but wasn't able to teach
it.
During the battle he was able to use his simple
domain to counter the sure hit effect while
simultaneously using RCT to heal his body.
Confused Yuji wonders how one even manipulates
there own cursed energy while RCT is active.
Again Gojo activates another use of the Simple
Domain before darting at Sukuna and attempting
to strike him.
In an instant he’s once again pounded by
the sure hit effect, layering Gojo with a
plethora of cuts.
AGAIN he activates another use of simple domain
and RCT causing Sukuna to call this all a
bit tedious.
Randomly though everyone back at headquarters
is taken by surprise when they see Gojo start
attacking Sukuna once more without using RCT
to heal himself.
Someone wonders if he’s running low on cursed
energy, but Yuta refutes it as there is frankly
no limit to Gojo’s cursed energy.
Speaking up though, Ino mentions that like
he said before the assumption rate could be
off.
Right after Domain expansion he started using
RCT at max output which uses up twice as much
cursed energy and thats not even taking into
account the fact Sukuna is also rushing Gojo
himself.
With the two powerhouses of the series rushing
at each other and the cuts not stopping, everyone
wonders if Gojo is about to lose.
Jumping on Sukuna and wrapping his hands around
the back of his head, Gojo activates Cursed
Technique Reversal, before leaning back and
pulling his hand up in preparation to end
the fight.
Blown away with what he’s just witnessed,
Yuta wonders if its even possible.
In his mind the reason he wasn't able to heal
himself for a moment was because he was using
RCT to heal his exhausted cursed technique.
Unleashing Red, Gojo shoots forth a blast
of reverse curse technique propelling Sukuna
back into the Shrine that makes up the center
of his Domain.
Noting that he somehow managed to survive
the blast, Gojo activates RCT to heal and
jokes that damn this dudes a pain in the ass.
Going more in-depth on the unfathomable feat
Gojo just did, Yuta explains that a cursed
technique which has been burned out by using
Domain Expansions is an entirely different
matter than physical damage.
Its like when a machine overheats, if it isn't
broken you have to let it cool down or it
wont work again.
Interpreting this, Maki makes it easier to
understand by saying that RCT can repair damage
but cant help with the cooling effect.
However it looks as if this understanding
of the ability is wrong.
Back in Shinjuku and having made it out of
the effective range, Gojo asks if Sukuna is
able to expand the size of his area?
Not even giving Gojo a second to think, Sukuna
expands the size of Malevolent Shrines Domain
to its maximum.
In the same moment, Gojo to the shock of everyone
expanded Infinite Void for a second time!
With everyone watching, they wonder if he’s
really dumb enough to just fall into the same
trap as before.
Mei notices it first though and Higuruma who
btw for a new sorcerer is so big brain, states
that he switched conditions on the external
and internal conditions of his barrier.
Which in simple enough terms for myself and
Yuji to understand, means that Gojo this time
is able to protect itself against attacks
from the outside.
Re-initiating the battle once more, both Gojo
and Sukuna trade hands back and forth, but
not once do the hits end up landing on either
side.
Jumping back, Gojo is absolutely blown away
as he understands that somehow Sukuna was
able to use his domain expansion and amplification
at the same time.
On top of that he’s becoming comfortable
inside of the infinite void and his cursed
energy output is increasing.
So in usual jujutsu combat you cannot use
an innate technique that’s etched into your
body while using Domain Amp.
But if you go and imbue your domain with a
technique itself then its an entirely new
situation.
Throwing a punch, Sukuna manages to dodge
back out of the way, however as he pushes
trying to strike Gojo, the six eyes manic
manages to evade the strike and thump the
side of Sukuna's body.
Managing to spin out of Gojo’s sight, he
quickly understands that somehow and while
inside of his own domain Sukuna turned off
his sure hit effect.
Knowing that the only ones who are unaffected
by infinite void are Gojo and anyone he touches,
Sukuna's plan is to expand his effective range
and increase the power of the binding vow
even further than he did in Shibuya with Megumi.
By using a binding vow, Sukuna is able to
further increase the power of his domain outside
of Gojo’s domain.
He does that by removing his sure hit guarantee
inside of the domain, while simultaneously
also keeping himself safe from infinite void
by touching Gojo.
Due to this all and again just like last time,
Gojo’s domain collapses and followed by
a plethora of strikes that seemingly knock
him away from Sukuna.
With everyone back at the TV station headquarters
place, whatever it is I honestly don't have
a clue, react in horror to what's going on,
Kashimo states that if Gojo dies he is going
out to fight next, so don't even try stop
him.
Over in Shinjuku, Gojo activates another technique
that he notes he hasn't used much since he
mastered his domain.
Kusakabe spits out his smoke in awe of having
seen Gojo use falling blossom emotion.
For those who forgot, its a secret art of
the big three families, an anti-domain technique.
All in all its an application of cursed energy
that automatically repels anything you touch.
It wouldn't ever be able to do something against
a complex domain like Infinite Void, but if
you’re up against something simple like
slashes its pretty useful.
Jumping in, Shoko just says that he most likely
used it so he can heal his burned out cursed
technique or at the least by some time.
AGAIN though like what is this the 3rd time
now, Gojo blows them all away as he activates
another use of Infinite Void.
Unlike all of the previous uses though, this
time its completely massive in comparison
and in Kashimo’s eyes it looks as if Gojo’s
trying to encapsulated all of Sukuna's domain
within his barrier.
Mei thinks its a bad move trying to expand
a domain to this size as it’ll drastically
lower its effectiveness and like Higuruma
states even if the domain isn't destroyed
its still pointless unless he wins inside.
Suddenly Gojo’s Domain cracks, putting everyone
watching on edge and making them think that
its about to fail.
Momo though quickly speaks up that no, its
not broken, infact the barrier is quickly
changing size and now its only a fraction
of its original size.
With Gojo’s Domain only the size of like
a basketball now, Kusakabe remarks that this
is frankly impossible, causing Mei to joke
about how many times they’ve said those
words today.
Maki curiously questions its outward appearance
and if the inside is that of a similar size.
Kusakabe agree’s with her as thats why when
your usually trapped inside you cant get out
unless you find the edge.
Even if you find that edge a normal domain
is resistant to attacks from the inside, so
escape is still limited.
What's most important when it comes to a barrier
technique is a concrete image.
Usually if you tried to envision a barrier
to small to hold yourself and an opponent,
it would just collapse.
Just like the prison realm though and probably
due to his time being confined in a small
place, its now allowing him to implement a
similar thing during the battle.
Still Kusakabe cant grasp the process around
how he’s able to change the conditions of
his domain each time he uses it.
Barriers particularly domain barriers typically
have a set internal and external parameter.
By discovering their own blend of these parameters,
every sorcerer is able to establish their
domain.
Confused as obviously this wasn't how Higuruma
and Hakari figured out their domains, they
open by default as a part of their technique.
In any case, they aren't usually things that
can be changed easily.
Kusakabe ponders if he changed the size of
his domain because it was to difficult to
maintain the large surface mass, so he had
to compress it to make things easier.
Or maybe it was because he wanted to see if
he could cover all of malevolent shrine with
an even larger barrier.
With Gojo’s domain beginning to shake back
and forth at such tremendous speed, the earth
itself begins to rumble.
Mei points out that even still Gojo’s domain
has managed to hold and Yuta states that Sukuna
also decreased his domain so he could increase
the output of his cursed technique.
So now pretty much, if this version of Gojo’s
barrier breaks they’ll enter a stalemate,
however Gojo will be on the backfoot, as he
will begin to run out of options.
Flashing back over to Shinjuku, Sadly once
more Gojo’s Domain is again shattered and
Sukuna emerges victorious for a 3rd time in
the domain struggle.
Having watched his sensei re-appear, Yuji
screams out for him, however in that moment
all of the other sorcerers are flabbergasted
as they witness Sukuna’s Malevolent Shrine,
start to crumble and fall to pieces.
On top of that, its shown that at some point
throughout the domain struggle, Gojo was able
to land a clean blow to the chest of Sukuna,
causing the king of curses to finally take
some proper damage.
Seeing this over their monitors, all of the
sorcerers scream in joy, believing that Gojo
still has a chance in this battle.
It was actually simultaneous, at the same
time Sukuna destroyed Gojo’s domain from
the outside, Gojo destroyed Sukuna’s domain
to the point he couldn't maintain it any longer.
Yelling at Miwa, Kusakabe asks if she kept
track, or if anyone kept track of the time
that Gojo’s barrier was active.
Speaking up, Mei reveals that it was out for
three minutes and 9 seconds, but if it was
more specifically after the moment it minimized,
then that was exactly 3 minutes.
Higuruma believes that now the domains have
collapsed neither of them will be able to
use their cursed techniques anymore.
If that is the case, Maki thinks Gojo can
make the first move since he can restore his
burnt out technique just like before.
But sadly Sukuna can also do the same with
RCT, and speaking up himself Yuta theorizes
he could probably do it to, though like he
said earlier, it cant be used to heal a burnt
out technique.
The reason that Gojo showing this to Sukuna
is terrible problem for everyone is because
back in the past Sukuna was able to split
his spirit 20 times into 20 different objects
called fingers.
After seeing this technique just once, Sukuna
learned how to turn himself into a cursed
object and now that he’s seen this new ability,
its most likely he’ll also be able to restore
his burnt out cursed technique.
In Shinjuku, Sukuna boosts his way up onto
a bridge, giving him a moment of peace before
noticing that random parts of the road start
to get smashed up from below.
Quickly jumping of the bridge and up onto
some railing, Sukuna notices Gojo break his
way through the ground behind him, then turning
back realizes his escape route was blocked
by a ball of rocks that Gojo had perfectly
floated there.
With no where to go Sukuna throws up his hands
to block and takes a kick that sends him sliding
back along the sidewalk.
Taking a moment to think about the fight,
Gojo wonders why Sukuna has been stubbornly
avoiding using any other cursed technique
than his own.
Even when the strength of the barrier was
lowered and Gojo had flipped the conditions
of it, he didnt try to destroy it from the
inside.
Instead he took the riskier option.
While they cancelled out each others sure
hit effects from within the domain, Sukuna
had no other choice but to use domain amplification
in order to beat his limitless cursed technique.
Which was a massive advantage for out man.
Still as he saw earlier, within a domain,
Sukuna is unable to use buildings to attack.
Infact until after Gojo’s domain was destroyed
he technically had the upper hand for over
3 minutes.
Yet in spite of that he cant seem to understand
why Sukuna didnt ever attempt to use something
from the ten shadows technique or Mahoraga
while in a domain.
He has the memory of Megumi and the conversation
that happened between them, so he knows for
a fact that someone of the exact same power
died to him.
Gojo just ponders if he’s scared he’ll
beat Mahoraga in once shot, however in that
exact moment, the wheel turns and blood begins
to drip from his own nose.
fug a nosebleed though, damn Gojo was baiting
our ass with that one and in an instant both
him and Sukuna threw up their hands to perform
another domain clash.
Yuji points out that again they activated
at the same time, and Angel who’s right
next to him brings up that Sukuna can now
restored his burnt out cursed technique or
maybe just decided to hide the use until now.
Kusakabe knows that within the next three
minutes that it should take for Sukuna to
destroy Gojo’s domain from the outside,
Gojo will need to damage Sukuna to the point
he cant maintain his domain.
Shoko joking that they shouldn't take as if
Gojo is on the backfoot yet brings up that
if Sukuna is hit at all by unlimited void
then mans done.
Due to this its certain that if Gojo is able
to destroy Malevolent Shrine within the next
3 minutes then Gojo will win this battle.
Inside of Shinjuku and having flared up his
cursed energy fists, Gojo pounds Sukuna with
a barrage of punches that really only bruise
the king of curses arms.
Jumping up Sukuna tries to quickly get over
to his shrine, however he’s knocked into
the floor then while incapacitated is grabed
by Gojo’s infinity and pulled towards himself.
Having been flung towards Gojo, Sukuna just
manages to block a devestating stomach punch.
Randomly though and im assuming mans used
Yuji’s divergent punch to delay the hit
of his cursed energy, Sukuna’s malevolent
shrine is completely destroyed while in the
exact same moment again, Gojos domain also
ends.
Falling to the ground and looking up, its
evident that this time Sukuna took a serious
blow as half of his face appears to currently
be missing.
With everyone believing that when it comes
down to domain struggles, Gojo is stronger,
they all hope deep within themselves that
he can win.
Throwing a fat right hook, Gojo sends Sukuna
straight back into the side of a bridge pillar
breaking it in the process.
Idek what we’re at now, like this is utterly
insane.
AGAIN Gojo and Sukuna launch another set of
domain struggles.
Yet unlike all of the previous battles, somethings
different here and Yuta cant help but feel
like maybe, just maybe, Gojo was able to expand
his domain earlier.
Inside of the domain struggle its revealed,
that Sukuna was indeed busy healing his body
and because of that he was late restoring
his cursed technique.
It was less that 0.01 seconds, but unlimited
void landed.
As an infinite set of infinite information
rushes into the cerebral cortex of histories
strongest sorcerer and the king of curses.
Our man, todays current demon, rushes forth
and pierces the chest of darkness incarnate.
Crazily enough, only 2 minutes and 40 seconds
after they last expanded their domains, Gojo
was able to collapse Malevolent shrine within
his innate compound.
With nothing, not even the friction in the
air available for Sukuna to use, he stands
there dumbfounded as the full effect of Satoru
Gojo’s infinite void connects with his body.
Not done yet himself, Gojo lets everyone know
that crushing his heart was only the beginning,
now he’s gonna take everything from him.
However before he’s able to connect with
Sukuna, a set of prolific words are spoken.
With this treasure, I summon...
Eight Handled Sword Divergent Sila Divine
General Mahoraga!
Skitzing out with the fact Sukuna managed
to summon him in that moment, Gojo just assumes
it hast had time to adapt to unlimited void
yet so surely he can destroy it in one shot.
Activating cursed technique reversal, Gojo
is just baffled when he witnesses Mahoraga
literally not care and instead with the sword
of extermination slashes down, completely
destroying Gojo’s infinite Void.
Falling to the ground, Gojo can only gasp
as he realizes that somehow Mahoraga had already
adapted to his domain expansion, allowing
him to attack freely from the inside.
Realizing that Mahoraga has been summoned,
Choso points out that it has the ability to
adapt to any attack, even unlimited void.
Using Reverse Curse technique and with Mahoraga
by his side, Sukuna knows that Gojo was well
aware of the shikigami’s abilities.
In this battle so far, both of the guys have
had their domains cancel each others out a
total of 5 times.
Gojo’s sire hit effect targeted everything
within the domain, whereas Sukuna’s sure
hit effect targeted everything inside his
domain, with the exception of himself.
This means that the sure hit effect targeting
Sukuna was still in place.
Crazily enough, one of the duo was able to
take on unlimited void 5 times, all while
shouldering the burden of Mahoraga’s adaption.
This person wasn't Sukuna though, no, it was
instead someone else.
Blown away with this revelation, Gojo quickly
figures that somehow he managed to adapt to
unlimited void within 0.01 seconds of his
domain opening.
Doing some more crazy deductions he figures
that like I said somehow Sukuna overcame the
burden of Mahoraga’s adaption ability, then
realizing he’s wrong he states that the
one actually taking the damage, was Megumi’s
Soul.
Deep into the conscious of Megumi’s mind,
we see him barely awake with Mahoraga’s
wheel floating directly above him.
Seeing Gojo now and wondering what's on his
mind, Sukuna asks what up, to which Gojo says
nothing really.
It just warms his heart to see him using such
fraudulent abilities.
Replying to this underhanded diss, Sukuna
states that unlimited void is an ability that
Gojo activates once inside of his domain.
He originally expected it to be a pain figuring
this out, and initially he planned to do neutralize
it first.
So while unable to use amplification within
the domain, Sukuna used Megumi’s soul to
adapt to unlimited void using his own ten
shadows technique.
As a result he wasn't able to use anything
other than what was originally imbued into
his domain.
Knowing that all Megumi took then was the
process of adaption, Gojo begins pulling up
his hand and remarking that Sukuna hasn't
actually adapted Megumi’s soul itself to
unlimited void, and if he opens his domain
once more, he’ll destroy him in one attack.
Not fazed over this though, Sukuna just laughs
and taunts Gojo while telling him that he’s
no longer able to open his domain.
Instantly and as he tries activating it once
more, blood begins streaming from his nose
and everyone back at headquarters, still watching
the monitors begin freaking out over the possible
outcome.
Having found a way in now, Sukuna remarks
that using RCT to heal his exhausted innate
technique looks to have strained his physical
brain quiet a bit.
To him its evident that his brain, more specifically
the prefrontal cortex where information on
cursed techniques is located, has been destroyed
and repaired too many times using RCT to heal
his burnt out technique.
Terrorfied at the fact Gojo had been using
such a wild technique, Yuta just screams that
this is way to risky.
They all know that the brain, especially that
section of the brain is the most important
and you cant even compare it to simply repairing
someone's normal bodily damage.
Shoko speaks up nervous over the fact she
assumed Gojo had got used to this effect on
his brain, however it looks like he’s suffering
now.
To top that off, Sukuna has done it fewer
times so he’s in a much healthier battle
condition.
Back in Shinjuku and as Gojo drops to one
knee, Sukuna states that Gojo has reached
his limit.
Even if he could've expanded his domain again,
he would've lost the instant he did.
Not to mention the fact, that he wouldn't
even be able to make it precise enough to
be a threat.
Taunting him like the demon he truly is, Sukuna
lets Gojo know that next up he’ll bring
the circumference of his domain inwards, from
there he’ll be left with no where to run
and as he carves him up, he’ll simultaneously
adapt to his infinity.
Saying his final goodbyes, he states that
Gojo was born into an era without Sukuna and
was hailed as the strongest.
Yet in the end, he just turned out to be plain-fully
ordinary.
Saying those prolific words, DOMAIN EXPANSION,
Sukuna proceeds to unleash his domain, however
in that moment all of his eyes begin bleeding
profusely and the domain fails.
So crazily enough, from the time of the previous
domain, this last conversation happened in
10 seconds, and yet just like Gojo.
Sukuna’s brain had sustained enough damage
to now make an expansion impossible.
Jumping up and laughing at Sukuna, Gojo just
notes that it looks like its hitting him pretty
hard now.
Then pointing at Mei’s crows, he knows that
all of his students are watching him put his
life on the line, so he’s gonna go ahead
and keep showing off.
Jumping forth with a speed Sukuna is unable
to keep up with, Gojo throws a fat right hook
to let his opponent know he still has a long
way to go to defeat him.
Over inside the main groups hideout, Kusakabe
asks who there had been seriously punched
by Gojo before.
A few people speak up noting that well he
didnt hit them, but they tried to punch him
as hard as they could and it was physically
impossible.
Due to no one having taken a hit, Kusakabe
who im assuming has, says that his fists are
enhanced with cursed energy and on the moment
of impact, blue repeatedly absorbs the surrounding
space.
It feels as if you’ve been counterattacked
after preparing for a regular blow.
Kirara wonders if it hurt, and Hakari along
with Yuta both reveal they puked after the
hit they took.
Nanami once said to Yuji that if he planned
on continuing as a sorcerer, then he shouldn't
compare himself to Gojo.
Nanami puts a massive deal of effort behind
his critical hits, but Gojo can casually perform
them as if its an everyday thing.
What Kusakabe was mainly trying to explains
was that from here on out, when it comes to
straight hands, he doesn't have a clue what
Gojo’s doing.
Back in Shinjuku its shown that Gojo is completely
dominating Sukuna in a physical fight.
He boosts down a building while smashing Sukuna
into every level, before turning around and
tossing him over to the road.
When Sukuna lands, Gojo uses all of the rubble
that had broken away from the building to
entrap the king of curses inside a brick coffin.
Exploding out of the reinforced brick, Sukuna
darts forth and quickly ducks a head kick
from Gojo.
Getting caught under in his trap, Gojo slams
his leg down, only to see Sukuna flip out
of the way and prepare his own axe kick.
All of a sudden he stops though, as he see’s
what seems like Gojo running at such a high
speed its begun creating a circle of after
images.
Thinking that he has the upperhand now, Gojo
darts in to strike, but Sukuna manages to
spot the real image and grab his hand, before
following up and punching him straight in
the face.
Being sent backwards Gojo quickly regains
his orientation and lands atop a street light.
Walking towards him, Sukuna explains that
Furu’s incantation, used to manifest Mahoraga,
along with the wheel represents complete circulation
and harmony.
Once Mahoraga has been attacked, the wheel
turns and the adaption begins.
With that said, the wheel turns and Mahoraga
seemingly adapts.
Gojo knows that when Sukuna uses domain amplification
and touches him, the wheel turns black.
Its safe then in his eyes to assume that it
interrupts and adaption process.
So if Sukuna cant activate his domain, but
can use amplification its probably because
the area of his brain originally damaged was
in charge of barrier techniques.
Over with Sukuna as he slowly strolls forth,
he thinks that Gojo is most likely only using
Lapse to avoid having his other techniques
adapted, which makes perfect sense.
As the lights go green, the two then rush
each other down once more, clashing in the
middle of the road.
With the light Gojo was just on, falling behind
Sukuna, he quickly grabs it and biffs it towards
Gojo, however it freezes as the object connects
with his infinity.
Back over with the main group they all note
that its random Mahoraga hasn't re-appeared.
Mei supposed that it had already adapted once
unlimited void was used for a fifth time.
Taking the knowledge in, Hakari deduces that
maybe the wheel has to turn a few times in
order for Sukuna to adapt to Gojo’s limitless
technique.
Just like they assumed and as Sukuna asked
if Gojo had been paying attention to his ability,
our man explains that he needs four spins
in total, which technically means only 3 more
spins of the wheel until Mahoraga adapts to
Gojo’s Infinity.
Walking towards each other again, Sukuna jokes
that they now have a countdown to when Gojo’s
idiotic smirk will be will be wiped from his
face, causing our goat to smile right back
and tell him the same.
In fact Gojo takes one step further saying
that he’ll beat him dead before he even
makes it to the 3rd spin.
Still eagerly watching the battle, Hana questions
if Gojo’s forgotten about Megumi to which
Yuji say’s that man really might have.
Hearing them and looking reading to throw
some hands himself, Kashimo jokes that its
fine, let em forget Megumi.
Needing to forget Megumi cause mans in a slightly
tight spot right now, Yuji watches as Mahoraga’s
wheel spins for the second time, meaning that
theres only 2 more spins until Gojo’s infinity
will be fully adapted to.
Turning his hands into perfectly constructed
orbs of blue cursed energy, Gojo flings them
at Sukuna, making him acrobatically flip out
of the way as the ability burns the bridge
from existence.
Capturing Sukuna within his range, Gojo sticks
both hands forth and creates more cursed energy
orbs that circle his target leaving them with
no where to escape.
Somehow escaping though, Sukuna managed to
duck down before darting off, causing all
of the orbs to immediately change direction
and start tracking his new position.
Boosting it around one of the nearby pillars,
Gojo fly's up and quickly blocks Sukuna’s
kick, having gained the advantage now, he
follows up by kicking his opponent down towards
the road below.
While falling, the wheel spins for the 3rd
time, making everyone back at the TV room
get more and more nervous over the impending
adaption.
Yuji curiously wonders if its time thats needed
for the Wheel to adapt, or is it battle experience?
Realizing what Yuji was trying to say, Kusakabe
solidifies his question by also pondering
if A) Does it take one attack then time for
the wheel to understand then adapt or, B)
is it adapting after taking multiple blows.
Still not even sure himself, he points out
that Gojo hasn't used anything other than
Lapse, so he doesn't even know and compounding
that Kashimo states that, either option is
possible, thats the reality of this situation.
Following the king of curses through one of
the nearby buildings windows, Gojo remarks
that from now on he’s gonna give him HELL.
In his eyes he’s convinced Sukuna that all
he’s using is blue, so with this timing
he wont be able to react.
Pulling up his hand and firing a point blank
shot of cursed technique reversal: red, Gojo
just watches as the wheel turns black, signifying
that Sukuna had activated his domain amplification.
As the technique hits and because of what
I previously just mentioned, Sukuna was just
barely able to minimize the damage in time.
Activating his RCT Sukuna to heal, Sukuna
thinks that he expected this, even if amplification
can neutralize the low output of limitless,
it cant fully cancel out blue or the reversed
red.
Yuji and Kusakabe both react in abject horror
as they realize that at this rate Sukuna will
fully adapt to his technique.
Looking heavily beaten and bruised, Sukuna
turns around to remark that Gojo is sloppy,
and questions if the greatest sorcerer of
today lost his cool once his hand was read.
Randomly though Gojo doesn't attack instead
he just tells his opponent that, ya know the
Red he just shot before.
Well it hasn't even exploded yet.
Taking one of the hardest back-shot's in the
figurative world that is Jujutsu Kaisen, Sukuna
gasps in pain as he realizes that he, the
king of curses was taken from behind?
Quickly calculating the buildings layout he
figures that Gojo must’ve planned from the
start to have red strike after 1 full lap.
Not giving him a chance to recover, Gojo follows
up and pounds Sukuna so damn hard with a black
flash that it physically knocks him out for
a moment.
Everyone back at the TV room just watches
in awe as they never even expected such an
ability to land, let alone be as successful
as it was.
Back in Shinjuku blood pours from Sukuna’s
mouth and the wheel falls symbolizing the
defeat of histories strongest sorcerer.
Randomly though the wheel picks up speed and
spins for the final time while at the exact
same time a stunned Gojo falls into a pool
of darkness and Mahoraga’s demonic hands
reach out for him.
With nowhere to go, Mahoraga grabs Gojo and
slices his chest with the sword of extermination
leaving everyone’s hope of survival on the
brink of destruction.
Beads of sweat drip from everyone's heads
as they worry about how things have taken
a turn for the worse with Gojo.
Since Mahoraga has arrived it means he’s
now completely adapted to Gojo’s technique.
Yuji however stays hopeful as in his eyes
Mahoraga only adapted to the infinity which
means its only an equal fight now, and Gojo
can heal up right away using RCT.
Standing nearby and looking absolutely stressed,
Shoko explains that she’s been smoking a
ton during the battle.
Sadly she thinks it isn't a case of just healing
up again, instead its more that Gojo’s healing
is gradually becoming slower than usual due
to his extended use of RED.
If the already prolonged fight continues it
might end up with him not being able to use
his Cursed Technique Reversal to heal as quickly,
therefore he could lose.
Though she does pose that the situation is
probably the same for Sukuna.
Gojo’s opponent is the KING OF CURSES.
Initially when the battle kicked off everyone
thought that it would be impossible for Gojo
to win and now with what they’ve seen that
thought is slowly creeping back in.
Even Gojo himself has begun thinking the same
thing.
Wondering how long its been since he felt
like this, it reminds him of a battle 11 years
earlier against Toji Fushiguro and how now
he’s beginning to feel the same satisfaction
from fighting, thats pushing him to an even
higher degree throughout this battle.
Being the strongest sadly comes with the title
of also being the loneliest and now the only
thing that will truly satisfy him is pure
dominance.
FLYING FORTH Gojo hits Mahoraga with a direct
punch that pushes the God shikigami back.
Instantly following up he tries to activate
RED in order to finish him off, but Sukuna
jumps back in and uses Megumi’s Rabbit escape
to cover Mahoraga and allow him to prepare
for the next attack.
Having watched his opponent try his best to
evade every attack, Gojo mocks Sukuna asking
him how long he’s gonna rest for after taking
the black flash and that it was pretty obvious
its effects are still hurting him.
Suddenly Sukuna mixes things up and throws
a fire extinguisher to cover himself and make
an opening for Mahoraga to attack Gojo.
Bursting through Mahoraga appears and attempts
to attack Gojo from above.
As Gojo is caught up in his fight with BIG
M, Sukuna uses a new application of Megumi’s
Max Elephant Shikigami to shoot a blast of
water that mirrors Choso’s piecing blood
technique.
Just as Gojo defends against Mahoraga, Sukuna's
attack lands & wounds his arm.
Flying backwards, Gojo quickly realizes that
Sukuna is mainly waiting for his infinity
ability to vanish, meaning that the fight
would turning into a pure 2 v 1 if it continues.
Annoyed he wonders how Sukuna is even able
to use the abilities of the Shikigami without
summoning them in the first place.
Like Megumi has to go through his whole procedure
whereas Sukuna can wear the wheel and summon
these Shikigami with what im assuming are
his thoughts.
Gojo knows that since Sukuna was able to adapt
to his infinity ability, he’s gonna have
to use more cursed energy, thats why he’s
been simultaneously using the Shikigami, however
he does explain that if Sukuna wants to adapt
to RED it would take much longer to do so.
Cutting his brainstorming off though, Sukuna
beams his way back into the picture while
stating that this isn't a 1 v 2 numpty.
Im the fraudulent one.
Moving his hands together, Sukuna Summons
a brand new Shikigami called the CHIMERA BEAST:
AGITO making this battle a 1 v 3 and putting
Gojo even further onto the back foot.
According to what i've seen the Chimera beast
is a mixture of Nue and Totality, which is
probably a combination I never ever saw coming,
and leaves sooo many other weird and hybrids
up for creation.
Gojo himself even jokes that with those 2
Giants standing there, Sukuna looks like a
lost child.
In a flash, the 2 beasts start the fight once
more with Gojo just barely being able to dodge
the initial attacks.
Randomly and stealing some more of Megumi’s
techniques, Sukuna pops out of Gojo's shadows
with his hands aimed like a pistol and shoots
another water blast like piercing blood from
Max Elephant’s ability but Gojo dodges that
too.
Slamming his fist down, Gojo just misses as
Sukuna flips back out of the way allowing
his boys to follow up with a dual hook punch
from either side.
Somehow dodging and arriving behind Mahoraga,
Gojo proceeds to blast him with red but its
barely even enough to burn the creature now.
Figuring that mans probably stuffed if he
doesn't do something absolutely insane, Gojo
deduces that he has to use this damn technique
in order to be able to finish Mahoraga off
in one shot!
Its a massive risk as Sukuna will most likely
notice the raised output, but its a risk he
has to take.
With a glimmer of hope and a cheeky grin on
his face, Gojo states that he’s got no other
choice, its time to use the UNLIMTIED HOLLOW
TECHNIQUE!
Well idk about everyone else here, but things
aint exactly looking good for Gojo at the
moment.
Kinda Gojover if ya catch my drift.
Like unless this insane technique works, we
might be in for another heartbreaking death,
WHICH as we all know is something Gege doesn't
hold back on.
The entire calling Sukuna fraudulent is a
great meme, but dude right now seems to be
implementing cursed energy in a way we’ve
never even seen it get used before, even Gojo
is confused with how mans able to activate
Megumi’s abilities without hand signals
or saying anything.
I wonder if we’re gonna get the BOX open
during this fight and I hope I didnt release
this video a week before the fight ends.
As of now I feel like we’re into the second
stage of this battle.
People from both sides could be showing up
to try and fight the injured sorcerers now,
Sukuna still has a plethora of abilities he
can use that we’ve never even seen and not
to mention Gojo’s Maximum or Unlimited Hollow
Technique.
If you did enjoy this fight and want to keep
upto date with Jujutsu kaisen in general,
then make sure to subscribe and also be sure
to leave a like as it truly helps out with
bringing a bunch of new people to this channel.
Again thanks for 170k subs, but for now its
been ya professional degenerate Diavolo and
ill see you all in a bit, bye!